Canadians are passionate about their
sports teams
generally those playing baseball
basketball and of course
ice hockey but more recently fans are
turning to a different game this is my
first time I've ever seen
success of the men's and women's sides
has caused a massive spike in interest
in the sport
the Canadian women's team won Olympic
gold in Tokyo followed by the men's team
qualifying for just their second World
Cup much of this success is down to the
influence of coach John Herdman John
Herdman has brought so much confidence
to the Canadian national team program
that it attracts winners right winners
attract winners he had metal success as
an Olympic coach for the Canadian women
he's more than brought that to the
Canadian men this group of players is
much more diverse than the team that
played at the 1986 World Cup in Mexico
among them the Canadian immigrant from
Ghana Alfonso Davies the Bayern Munich
player has captured the attention of the
soccer World and is thriving under
Herdman while croatian-born Milan borian
tells everyone how proud he is to be
part of this team happy to bring to give
back something to Canada that Canada
gave it to me you know New Life new
everything experts think the World Cup
could be a a turning point for the sport
in Canada now this is an opportunity to
be there in in Qatar this year and then
in Canada United States and Mexico in
four years this will set a real
transition for Canada to the next level
the recent success is already paying off
with greater enrollments in youth
programs and fans ready for a taste of
World Cup Glory
with hopes of being a dark horse
Canadians are counting down to the
tournament in Qatar with excitement not
felt in a generation Jody Vance Al
Jazeera Vancouver